kelly
is with us kelly is in chicago hi kelly
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave and anthony thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um so i'm 26 years old and i live at
home with my parents debt-free
um but i lost my job back in july um i'm
calling right now my boyfriend tyler
next to me
um we've been dating for almost seven
years now he's also living at home with
his parents to save money and pay off
debt
but we want to move out we're not only
just looking to move out we want to
relocate down to arizona
so we're just kind of wondering when's
the right time to do that
specifically what money do we use to
make that move
and whether one or both of us need to
find a job before moving
um kind of the biggest issue with this
situation is um
my parents kind of want to control how i
use my money
i've already tried having a conversation
with them about wanting to move and they
told me no
why did they tell you no kelly i think i
know why i don't know why
why did they tell you no so they think
that i don't
have enough saved up how much do you
have
two um so i have an account that they
had set up for me with their financial
advisor
that's in my name now that has a little
over 28 thousand dollars
and then i have um 19 000 in a personal
savings account
and how much does yours how much does
your boyfriend have
um he is on baby step number one
finishing that off
and he has um sixty six thousand five
hundred in debt
and no money
um he's about halfway done with baby
steps
how old is he he's also 26.
what was his job that he lost
i lost my job oh i thought he lost his
job does he have a job
yes he does what's he do he
works in food he works in a lab doing
research and development
he does a lot of like formulating
himself what's he make
he makes 36 000. okay what's he going to
do if you move
to arizona um he's already found a job
that's pretty much
the same kind of thing that he wants to
apply to apply to okay
and it would and it would pay around the
same amount
um we're thinking a little more because
it's with a bigger company the company
that he's at now is family owned and
it's a little smaller
if you were his daughter would you want
you marrying him
is he a provider
he wants to be oh i asked you
if you were your if you had a daughter
that was dating this guy would you want
your daughter
marrying him
i mean we've been together for seven
years
i didn't ask if you'd been in a bad
relationship for seven years
i asked if this is a good guy that you
would tell
your own daughter to marry twice you've
avoided the question now that's not good
that's not good killer and and he's on
speakerphone with you ask him the same
question well he want his daughter to
marry him
he's not on speakerphone with me right
now oh okay i thought you said he was
next to you i'm sorry
he he is but he cannot hear i took it
off speakerphone
[Laughter]
but the issue is my dad kind of holds
his debt against
him and that's kind of been a big issue
in his relationship
and here it is kelly dave is coming from
a father perspective your answer is no
he would not if you were his daughter
he's telling and i don't know what that
is i don't know whether he's got work
ethic issue
or why he hadn't addressed his debt
right or what's going on
but um uh i i'm not saying that his debt
if i i disagree with your dad his debt
does not make him ineligible right
okay so i'll i'll slow down here
i i'm just i i want you to start
thinking that way
because you're making uh really big
decisions you have a pile of money he
has none
right and um that's what's scaring your
parents
part of it and the fact that he's not
made much progress
in the in the years that he's been
working towards paying off this debt
the debt is not the problem he just
doesn't seem to be making any progress
now he's trying to drag
your their daughter off to the other end
of the world away from them and
and so i kind of get where they're
coming from a little bit
so i i um if you were my daughter and he
was my potential son-in-law here's what
i would tell you
okay and you guys get to do whatever you
want to do by the way but you called us
and asked yes
and anthony you can disagree with me you
can jump in here okay i will
but um i know
so i'm coming he's right i'm coming at
this from the grandpa side or
or the dad's side okay because i've got
kids that are just a little bit older
than you kelly all right
okay and so if you were my daughter and
and he was my
tell you what put him on speakerphone i
was busy open the speaker
open the speaker up so that he can hear
me too okay
okay i don't want to talk about i don't
talk about anybody except for everybody
can what's
what's his name kelly tyler hey tyler
how are you
good dave how are you good man thanks
for joining the conversation yeah so
what i was just telling kelly was based
on what she told me
and anthony we're gonna advise the two
of you
and i'm gonna advise you guys as if you
were my kids
as she was my daughter and you were a
potential suitor
for one of my daughters and i have two
daughters that are married and
my kids are slightly older than you and
they have great lives and i want great
lives for kelly and for tyler okay
yes okay so what i would personally tell
you is
that you do not need to go to arizona
until
you have jobs lined up and they ought to
be
they ought to be enough job she needs to
have enough job to support her household
and the households need to be
separate and you need to have enough job
to support your household
correct the only way you would do that
differently than that would be if one of
you had the job and another one didn't
would be if you got married before you
went to
um before you went to arizona because i
don't want you to combine your
households as your dad
until you're married and uh that sounds
like a dinosaur it sounds like old
school but i just told you i'm doing
this
as if you were my own kids this is how i
would advise you because i want i
want you to when you're my age and
you're 60 i want you to look
back on this time and go i really like
that 26 year old young couple
they were wise because i haven't always
been wise in my life guys
and it leaves a mark it leaves a scar
and you don't want to do that so um
that's what i would tell you is you've
been dating seven years you may be ready
to get married i don't know
seven years is a long time it's probably
time to paint or get off the ladder but
uh
so but if you're not ready to actually
say we're going to do this thing
we're going to combine your debt tyler
and her
money we're going to combine both these
incomes we're both going to go get in
at least one income and shortly
thereafter get the other one as a
married couple in arizona and start our
lives
if you're gonna do all that i'm ready
i'll go with you let's do it
yeah tyler do you love her a simple
question okay cool great
i'm gonna give you a part b to dave i
agree with everything dave save y'all
got a route that's great let me tell you
what i would do if i was 27 and i love
this young lady
as a man i'm going to go to arizona i'm
going to get a job get a solid job
start aggressively working towards my
debt i must go there for a year
establish a foundation
then i'm gonna come back and i'm gonna
propose to her and we're gonna get
married quickly
and then together we will move back once
everything is
solid ooh and you know what else that
does i'll give you another thing that
impresses her dad that's what i was just
about to go to
as much as you can he may be a jerk you
may not be able to impress him but
most dads would go this guy's a stud he
went up he went out and laid a
foundation
earned my daughter's hand these are all
old-fashioned ideas
right guys yeah yes sir but
they're ideas that um they the reason
that they were there was they caused
people to join their lives in a way that
that
gave them a better chance at winning
yeah so you guys do what you want to do
you're 26
you're more than capable of making your
own decisions we're not
you we didn't call you you called us so
you you know
you got our input now you guys can
decide i like that part b
i like part b too i think you're better
than me this might be good yeah
this is the dave ramsey show you man
you know you're in here helping you're
the co-host so uh
and you're out there you know you're out
there in the dating field yourself so
i ain't no you got to go you got to go
talk to some dad i sure did
his daughter and he gonna see my
foundation
[Laughter]
have him have him call me i'll talk to
him listen i'll tell him you're all
right hey thank you dave